[Music]
CBD you might have noticed those three
letters cropping up online or in your
social media feeds lotions oils dog
trees so what is CBD it's cannabis and
people are turning to it to treat all
kinds of things I use it for anxiety it
helps me because it's just gonna take
the edge off I only started about a week
ago and I'm still not consistent with it
but I started using it for sleep and I
use a anointment that I rub onto my knee
I can reach my back I do it but I just
use about my name right now but
scientists worry about the lack of
research a lot of the perceptions of the
ability of cannabidiol to have a wide
range of disease states and symptoms
really comes from media and marketing
and about the lack of regulation people
have taken what they thought was the CBD
product or a hemp product and it was
contaminated with other things and they
did show up to the ER they did have
adverse consequences
[Music]
America has a complicated history with
cannabis but to be honest until recently
I have no idea what CBD even is let
alone that it's cannabis I was seeing it
pop up in shop signs and an adverse but
it wasn't until friends that started
talking about using it that I really
looked into CBD and how it's being used
CBD cannabidiol is a chemical compound
from the cannabis plant but it's not the
chemical that cannabis is traditionally
known for that's THC you might not
recognize the name but that's the stuff
that gets you high CBD however doesn't
have any psychoactive effect and it's
now legal for American farmers to grow
cannabis also known as hemp that can be
used to manufacture CBD but the THC
content has to be lower than noir point
three percent I wanted to have a look at
the different options out there for
someone curious about CBD what kind of
thing would you recommend I would start
with something like the flower so this
one obviously looks a lot like weed the
police might get confused but you are
welcome your rights to have this
absolutely you're a 100% your rights
this is Bree Rafael she co-owns a CBD
shop in Charlottesville Virginia I
struggled severely with depression and
anxiety and I respond negatively to
pharmaceuticals even something as simple
as ibuprofen my body is just
hypersensitive and any any time I've
tried taking medicine to treat mental
health the side effects have been far
worse than the mental health itself with
CBD I can come in here and spend it's
about $200 a month where I have to spend
250 just to see my physician let alone
the medication and follow-up
appointments and how do you take CBD it
really depends on what I'm treating I
will take the tinctures morning and
night that you'll take directly under
your tongue and if I
having spikes of anxiety I'll smoke some
of the CBD flower manufacturers are
seizing on the commercial potential of
the cannabis plant but the Food and Drug
Administration the FDA hasn't yet
created regulations for the CBD industry
this is where it gets complicated recent
changes in US federal law mean the hemp
is no longer classified as an illegal
substance but the FDA says it is illegal
to put CBD in food all claim that it has
a therapeutic benefit so why all these
products allow to appear in shops and
online well the FDA is focusing on
businesses making really bold medical
claims they've sent warning letters to
companies advertising CBD as a treatment
for cancer and Alzheimer's disease to
get FDA approval products have to go
through rigorous scientific testing like
epidural ax a CBD pharmaceutical drug
designed to treat epileptic seizures so
how does CBD actually work
cannabidiol is a very messy drug and
it's hypothesized to have tens of
different actions on different sites in
the brain and the body so if it can be
acting through all these different sites
it can potentially have lots of
different effects at the end of the day
people are taking cannabidiol
supplements and they're reporting that
it helps them sleep they're reporting
that it helps them with pain they're
reporting that helps them with a wide
range of conditions but to date there's
been very little controlled study of
cannabidiol
so it seems scientists aren't exactly
sure how CBD acts in the body but there
are plenty of people out there who
believe it works and are eager to invest
Grahame Redfern is a farmer in Virginia
who has just started growing him for CBD
he also has his own brand of products
named after his dog Draper I took him to
the vet and they did an ultrasound on
him and he had five massive tumors I
went to the store about CBD oil gave him
five drops in his food and then five
hundred song and they told me at the vet
he had five weeks to live and I gave it
to him for a year and a half after that
and he lived happily up until the day
[Music]
Graham thinks more research will prove
more benefits of CBD but for now
he knows it's all about wording
marketing is everything with this we are
not a medical company we are not making
any medical claims we are producing a
product from a plant that people can do
as they please with it this farm is a
family business
Graham's mom Patti is also one of his
customers I started using it about four
months ago because I have arthritis in
my thumb and my son said mom just try
rubbing it on your hand and see if it'll
work because that's what most people are
using it for at your age so I started
using it once in the morning and once at
night and believe it or not it my hand
does not hurt anymore the people that
are buying these parts and using them
what kind of person is using them well
most of them are just some girlfriends
of mine that are in any industry every
industry housewives bankers I'm a banker
attorneys builders just anybody I come
in contact with that most of them are
buying for their mothers or
mother-in-law so how do these rave
reviews tally with the science in the
clinical studies that have been done
thus far what's been shown to be
effective have been significantly higher
doses than what is actually available in
traditional cannabis dispensaries are
available online a lot of the
perceptions of the ability of
cannabidiol to help a wide range of
disease states
really comes from media and marketing at
this point and how did the CBD products
currently available hold up under
scrutiny in a study that looked at 84
items bought online 58 that's nearly 70%
were incorrectly labeled 36 products
actually contained higher levels of CBD
and 22 contained lower levels than the
labels stated none of the products
listed THC as an ingredient but it did
appear in 18 of the samples and it's not
just THC that could be a problem
last year there were a bunch of military
servicemen in North Carolina that bought
hemp products from a shop that was just
like the one you were describing and
they all went to the ER with kind of
acute cardiovascular effects psychotic
effects that suggest that the products
that they consumed contains synthetic
cannabinoids the World Health
Organization has said that CBD in its
pure state doesn't appear to cause harm
and people who use it are emphatic about
its benefits but without regulation
consumers aren't currently protected and
demand is only increasing
[Music]
while the science has shown that CBD can
treat certain types of epilepsy more
research needs to be done to see if it
can be effective for other conditions
this will take some time but for many
companies and consumers there's no
turning back
CBD has already gone mainstream
[Music]
you